і зовсім недавно Олександр Шилка вінків
і у я виданий світ що будуть чоловік і знайти
кат неабияку москву to proceed і
політичний портулак в Україні
астані сир і bull і не прости плескати
мусаев хвилини інститут працювати його
набрав і банківські картки блоку валу а
крем тофу був це по груші волопаса ди
ти за тероризм серце кожен активіст
через його політичні підлоги ряди мій
улюблений закоханий плакат wingate бути
країни починаючи з 2000 уроку кабіни
законно прийшов до влади прозвали україну
шлях ще й політичні репресії
роздруківки проти б всю провину rus почала
вбивчу війну почав про протестне
руси олександр 16 rocker u percerin
вийшов на метан їх проти фальсифікацій
на виборах до гордуми 2011 методу плескати
активний учасник акції та пікати його на
приклад на замовлення по литві я з ним грати
кремлівських окупантів а виплати політики
кремля щодо україни українці
брат і навік та україна ми з тобою
10 за приманити за повстання 2 роки
переважно за пару шані встановленому
порядку харчування справа це не мітинг у
росії c кримінальний найкращим перше це
вершина 30 гіпс акцію дівчинку надій
савченко інший вісь акція на до 3
ненависним скла розгорнути або
набили суду без убила мого друга
ільдара дадіна
мені тут дали п'ять чи днестративного
арешту ще один арешт і на ступні 5 руки
Олександр ними і ви маєте рацію я став їздити
етап ервін таке рішення
влади про ворожіння статусу політичного
біженця і дуже розруху і треба допоміг
україни у які хлопець їхній майдан у
короткий термін короткий термін люди
змогли самоорганізовуватись у Росії
таке щоб не забудьте така
горизонтально самоорганізація б сбу
диких лизали без жодних лідерів
Олександр вірить місяця - розміну влади в
Росії а його московські друзі такі ж
активісти радіус дорівнює у би заспівати це
зможе продовжити свою діяльність